Introducing Photo Filters.
Ah, San Francisco: Land of a million vacation photos.
And here's Phil!
Phil has filled his phone with photos and is using Twitter's photo editor to tweet them out.
Let's learn how.
While composing a tweet, Phil taps on the camera icon...
...and then navigates to the photo he would like to use.
That's the one!
And now he's ready to edit.
As you can see, there are three icons at the bottom.
The first one automatically enhances your image for a quick fix.
The icon on the right allows you to crop the image,...
...move and scale your photo and select either original or square.
Finally, clicking the center option allows you to choose a filter for your photo.
Tap one of the filters to see it up close or swipe the image to try another.
There we go!
Phil's finished, so he clicks "Done",...
...and he's ready to send his tweet and share the photo.
All of his fabulous filtered photos show up on his home timeline,...
...wonderful memories from the City by the Bay.
We here at Twitter hope that you enjoy these new features, and as always, happy tweeting!